foreign
thank you
all right welcome everybody
uh wow wait a second what is going on
here
do I have everything I need to have
I don't I don't I'll be right back okay
stand by with me
foreign
thank you
all right I think we're actually ready
now
um it has been a crazy day trying to get
set up uh in the new bunker for today's
stream
I guess technically I've done it because
we're live but I want to warn people
my Elgato
hd60 has been freezing a lot
and when it happens
can you guys even hear me can people
hear me oh you can okay hold on let's
see if we have audio
all right welcome we are live here in
Perry Georgia as we get ready for seven
okay
we do good all right we have audio
um it's gonna be this this stream is
going to be a work in progress okay
folks but we are standing by for Trump
it's so exciting to be here with
everybody but we are definitely going to
have uh some uh possibilities of
problems today in terms of the audio
video sync
I did the best I could
um
I would refresh because to me it's
sounding okay
uh if people want to tell me
exactly what the offset is I'm glad to
try to fix it if people want to tell me
you should do plus 80 or minus 80. let's
see if I can even monitor my own stream
and figure out uh
where is my twitch stuff by the way
let's just get set up here
David packman
dashboard
everybody relax we're gonna work it out
it's gonna be fine
off by one second not sure about that
let me
listen to it myself and see uh see what
we've got here see how far off it is
listen to the offset is massive see what
we've got oh you know what it might be
let me take a listen hold on
that's pretty solid uh offset
that's pretty solid offset yeah
um all right let's let's explore a
couple possibilities here
um
we're going to look at what we are doing
using a custom audio
device which I think is what
so my entire video just froze but now
I'm back did it fix the audio offset
that's the first question
that would be the first question
the audio is synced now
oh it's much better let's just see if it
holds okay guys I'm gonna do absolutely
the best I can this is my first day
streaming from this setup and I really
hope that it that it goes well
um I'm streaming from Hassan's old
apartment so like as you can imagine you
know I have his old equipment now
and it's not uh it's not all the best
okay very good
um I have a few I'm kidding guys I'm
kidding I'm kidding but I'm gonna do the
best I can as far as the tech goes uh if
people know about the hd60 and what
causes the freezes and I obviously I've
Googled it none of the suggestions
online helped me in any way so uh
somebody really knows how to deal with
this stuff let me know okay uh computer
computer's good and it shouldn't be an
issue of like get a new computer and all
of those all of those things we have a
funny situation today
Donald Trump is going to be doing a
rally in a Georgia
and the ardit of Arizona just finished
and Trump lost by even more now that
we've learned about the results check
this out
GOP review
finds no whoa hold on a second
my zoom is different over here on this
shot
see if we can fix that
there we go okay guys I'm we're working
it all out GOP review finds no proof
Arizona election stolen from Trump
obviously but the really funny part
is this right here
even that partisan review
came up with a vote tally that would not
have altered the outcome finding that
Biden won by 360 more than the certified
results so this entire recount this
entire thing that we've done
we figured
out actually Biden won by even more by
360.
just a another humiliation
um and it's just like humiliation after
humiliation after humiliation it's it's
Bonkers it's Bonkers
um I muted myself now
just lost audio
testing testing so here there's no audio
was was there he there was no audio when
we were over here
but then here there is audio
it's very strange
now the audio is lagged
now I'm good
yeah I I don't know guys some people are
saying it's out of sync some people are
saying it's in sync it's uh some people
are saying it's Backstreet Boys I don't
know
I'm laggy again it muted and then came
back de-linked
now it's delayed
all right let's see if we can fix that
I'm starting to
all right now I'm back
yeah something weird is going on if
anybody in all honesty if anybody knows
about
um
Elgato hd60 with Windows 10 and what can
cause these issues please let me know
um I have had uh
I've had some of these issues before
we're going to try to just keep it here
to prevent too many problems from uh
from happening so we're in Perry Georgia
let's listen a little bit to the sights
and sounds here as we await uh Donald
Trump's standby us georgian's a small
town Georgians to be proud of it is all
right let's talk about ways you can
watch this broadcast if you're watching
us right now on Rumble YouTube Facebook
that's great make sure you're following
us across all the platforms I would
recommend not watching on Rumble
I would I would just watch this channel
uh well we're going to have it and it's
going to be fine
um I would not go to any of this
nonsense this doesn't this doesn't seem
like good stuff uh I would I would stay
away from it okay let's look at
get a few super chats just to see what
we've got
hey is it me or is there a weird audio
delay yes there is a weird audio delay
we're working on it
David sir your thoughts on China
releasing the two Michaels back to
Canada
I have no idea I've never heard of that
story I apologize
I was hoping you'd be like
live for the AZ Senate stream yesterday
did you watch it three hours of
admitting there was no fraud no I didn't
watch it I was I was busy actually
setting up the new bunker
thoughts on AOC present vote I I
actually don't even know it I've been
completely disconnected I've been
completely disconnected from this stuff
for uh some period of time
we're back to audio delay
hmm
so right there really like nothing
nothing happened
muted and desynced yeah it's like I'm
not I'm just I'm touching nothing here
it really doesn't make sense
I would like to get it working correctly
before things get too crazy today
uh
yeah I wonder
could it be a USB thing is that possible
it's not a bandwidth issue absolutely
not we've got gig
it's not a
it's certainly not bandwidth I mean what
I could try is just getting underneath
the table
and
um using a different
USB and seeing if that fix it fixes it
let me let me just try that okay I'm
just gonna I'm gonna black
[Music]
foreign
hello hello
how are we doing guys
did anything get better
now it's synced hmm
all right
let this is not a particularly
auspicious beginning I'm not gonna lie
um
but we'll see I do want to say thank you
to Jacob Aston for signing up on my
website using this new coupon code
dystopian rally the coupon code today it
is a little trickier to spell
and it does require being accurate from
the standpoint of spelling the code is
dystopian rally because that's what
we're expecting to see here it's very
ominous it's sort of reminiscent of
Orwell and these types of things
um
but worse things can happen so my
expectation I I see a lot of people
saying David is Trump going to address
the fact that they finished the recount
in Arizona and he lost by even more
he will probably say something like the
recount was
taken over by bad people or something
like that and we can't trust the audit
it's not a recount the audit
um and he'll say we we need to recount
other states that's my guess I mean
Trump has not admitted that he was just
wrong like does anybody in the chat
think that Trump is going to show up and
say hey guys you know what they did the
ardit and we really lost
so we just good good for Biden I mean
you know what I made a mistake I didn't
really win I lost of course not
of course not Donald Trump does not has
has never done that
um so he's not going to show up today
and uh do that that's for sure uh let's
see what our audio mix is like let's
just listen here guys
let's Donald Trump is this is the type
of dialogue that they have who can hit a
ball further who could have a bigger
ball
who could pop the ball
um it's it's wacky it's absolutely wacky
all right let me get to a couple of
things I do have 500 voicemails that I
could play uh I'm not gonna do that
right now because
quite frankly I don't know that that
would be legal
um but we're gonna we're gonna uh we may
get to some of the of the more milk
toast voicemails in a little bit
um let me do oh hold on let me do a
couple more Super chats uh
let's see
Trump is David's daddy says Jimmy from
Philly who has been a member for seven
months thanks for the seven months Jimmy
Raven says why do you need a bunker just
curious I'm I've been advised not to say
uh oh
did something happen to the audio when
when I started reading super chats
see why is that happening that doesn't
really make any sense
when I went to the Super chats it
desynced
does that give us any insight into into
what's going it seems to be when I go to
a different window
it's causing some kind of an issue I
mean it's not literally the super chats
causing the problem but it must be
something about me full screening that
window here
mute that I haven't muted anything
that's the thing
the earbuds are not Bluetooth
the earbuds are not Bluetooth
that that's really strange
let's see if I can uh
what did that do for us can people still
hear me
can anybody hear me right now
now it's synced
okay I was using a custom audio capture
device now I'm not
just it's weird
it's weird
no it has nothing to do with using a
different mic okay I'm gonna try to pull
up the super chats okay let's see what
happens now
Super Chat Super Chat I think
I love you says Tristan and super chats
are showing and will rsbn talk about the
Arizona audit did that disable it
did that happen did it mute again
yes and it lagged
that's really weird
that just it just doesn't make sense
there's no explanation as to why that
would happen
all right so I'm guessing I'm back to
synced now the guys this has nothing to
do with twitch only there's people like
just just be only on Twitch
it's a hardware issue on my end which
we're trying to figure out
um it's back to synced so could it let
me ask this there's a few different ways
to do window captures
could it be the window capture mechanism
because there's three let's see what the
options are
you can do automatic bit bit or Windows
10.
could that be a problem should I be
doing a Windows 10 let's see
hmm
that's strange
see if we can fix that
now the Firefox window's gone altogether
that's very weird
see what happens if I close that out
so am I synced right now like as far as
the audio goes are we okay right now
like as of right now is the audio okay
test one two
it's a bit out on Twitch I'm more out of
sync
it's a disaster
okay
I'm uh
I'm committed to
okay
um
now there is this thing called buffering
and and it says Auto detect I can enable
or disable I wonder if that could be the
setting that's causing the problem
it's not a mic issue
foreign
testing one two
so how are we doing now
flashback recording do you mean like to
be able to go back and repeat
like do reruns uh like a replay buffer
the replay buffer is off
all right
all right let's try
all right how are we doing now
we doing any better I changed a couple
settings and it on my end it looks a lot
smoother
okay I turned off this buffering setting
let's see what that does and then let's
see
testing testing one two I moved to
another window but without picking it up
did that mess it up
or are we still okay right now
still okay
oh that's interesting okay I picked up
another window so let's see then
all right
and then stream labs
all right
and we're gonna add a uh
all right well I think at least for now
we're going to have to get rid of the uh
super chats
no super chats for the time being uh we
just can't do it we just can't do it
folks it's just not uh something about
it's not working right
yeah
so all right it'd be great if someone
can help me troubleshoot this stuff but
it's not um
it's not the best
maybe I shouldn't even be using the
Elgato hd60 like maybe I should go back
to my Blackmagic shuttle maybe the hd60
just isn't good
could that be
certainly seems plausible
just hard to get that shuttle the
intensity shuttle anymore
we'll have to look into that
let's take a listen and see what's going
on but his Old Guard influence on the
Republican party with Liz Cheney
specifically him holding a fundraiser
for her they're trying to appeal to the
donor class she's not getting small
dollar donations
wait now hold on guys now when you're
saying when you're saying that it's now
unsynced
is it the video we're watching isn't
synced as far as you guys are concerned
or is it my audio and video
was was that was the was the video we
because that's two different issues
just me
okay okay
um
all right
well the one other thing I can try
is just adding a separate
audio
let's see if I could just separate this
testing one two
testing one two
testing one two one two
okay so what I did now is instead of
using the audio channel that was part of
the video capture I just set set up a
separate audio channel on the same basis
okay
do I have a pacman live Channel you can
try man some people guys this has
nothing to do with YouTube or twitch
it's it's a hardware issue
right here in the room with me
let's now I'm going to let's listen to
this video and see if it messes with
mine okay still trying to segregate
School I saw Arizona State University
they're trying to run white kids out of
this video section it's disgusting it's
despicable it's wicked yeah you probably
are remember the club that Mike's
talking about testing testing one two
all right so we did something else and
then I came back to myself is it still
okay
it's still okay
okay
um
wondering if I should try adding
the super jets
uh
we can try it
we'll give it a shot while we wait here
um still synced so far okay all right
stay with me guys I I'm opted we have we
have time I'm optimistic we're going to
get to Super chats we're going to get to
voicemails
so far okay yeah we're all learning
together
there's a lot to learn that's for sure
let's get logged in here
then we'll see if we can get these super
chats going I think once we actually
figure out what the issue is I think the
streams will be much more resilient and
much stronger
uh and my ability to troubleshoot will
be greatly enhanced
we've got wired internet gigabit
that's not the issue
let's take a look here and see what we
can find
yeah we're synced at levels that I've
only read about on the internet
okay
so we are momentarily going to
no no guys it's not an Ethernet
that has to be Grim Reaper 83 tell me
you're trolling please tell me this is
not an ethernet cord issue
um okay we're gonna try to now get
another window capture and let's see if
we can get our so we will call this
Super Chat window
well that is not it
let's see where it is Firefox
yeah that's not gonna work
um you know what you know what it could
be it could be that people are sending
me faxes that could be it
that really could be it
um
all right let's see
it's a five and a quarter incher
okay you know what we can do this will
be fine I'll still read super chats they
just aren't going to show up on the
screen it's really no big deal
like it's fine
I'll just I'll just read them and we
will uh
we'll we'll move this to the middle here
we can even make it a little bit bigger
there we go I think we'll be fine
good okay
the route oh and by the way Katya the
the actual right side broadcasting video
is a little bit unsynced that's that
that may be actually confusing things
it's not the same though I really miss
him arriving I'm gonna refresh it
because I'm even hearing that unsynced
let's see now this feels wrong that he's
not arriving in Air Force One anymore
it's just it's just but you know what's
funny right with me this guy's extremely
mentally ill very very mentally ill like
it's actually crazy uh that he even has
a presence on a on a television channel
that's that's really pretty wild stuff
um
okay all right we're standing by for
Donald Trump so let's get right into it
I've got a couple of other things to
show you guys
uh what was this
this was not the article I had
oh no that's nothing okay
um Charlie Kirk he's very worried that
white demographics in America are not
being protected
you guys want to listen to this listen
to this insanity
if Texas started to make the visual that
they are going to arrest and Deport them
as their own State this would Inspire
acts of courage amongst Republican
Governors all across the country
this is what Charlie Kirk's definition
of courage
may not align with yours and mine
inspire a movement of states starting to
step up and enforce the law not defy the
law but enforce the law
we did nothing when Illinois
New York and California Oregon and
Washington past Sanctuary State measures
and Sanctuary City measures saying that
we are not going to
we are not going to comply with ice
we're going to do things our own way
we're already in that constitutional
that post-constitutional questioning
moment it's funny that like
there's actually adults
who sometimes go
how does what's happening right now in
the world
interact with the Constitution of the
United States
let's see what Charlie Kirk has to say
about that there's actually people who
do that
so the real the open-ended question
remains
what are we going to do about it
we'll cut 80 DHS reports they've
deported 1.7 000 Haitians but they've
allowed 3 000 to come into America
Texas allowed this to happen Texas could
have intervened okay we have a tech
question
do you have more than your normal amount
of browser windows open not
not really I mean I do have a bunch of
browser windows open I will cop to that
I will cop to that is could could that
alone be a problem
um
I mean I don't know it's not been a
problem before
but it's an interesting question
could that be a ram issue let me let me
admit I'm going to admit something to
you guys the computer I'm streaming from
today
only has eight gigs of RAM and typically
I'm on I'm on a unit with 16.
could that actually be causing these
problems
open task manager
is that Ctrl shift Escape
task manager
uh task manager performance memory
it's currently using six of eight gigs
oh no that's terrible right
six of eight gigs that seems that
doesn't seem could that be the problem
guys
people are saying that that's totally
fine and then other other people saying
no
if it's peaking at eight out of eight
you know what I'm gonna do let me switch
browser window and see what it does to
the memory usage okay I'm just gonna
switch switch over
didn't do a thing to it
didn't do a thing to it
um
see what else we've got here
download some Ram yeah maybe I should do
that maybe the eight gigs of RAM is a
problem I mean is it is it conceivable
that that could be oh and I shouldn't be
using Chrome at all
that's interesting
um okay I mean I can get off of Chrome
let's get over to our own uh
let's close Chrome
and now we're over on Firefox
let's see if that gives oh it's almost
like already performing better
huh it actually already feels a little
bit smoother just like the whole
computer dollars I mean it seems like
over the last 18 months we've kind of
built a parallel economy
they want to keep uh conservatives out
they want to keep Freedom loving people
out of businesses they want to every
corporation wants to engage in politics
to their own detriment and it's to the
benefit of Rumble and my pillow oh no
not more Rumble stuff the conservative
Browns coffee shop over in St Petersburg
great that's a lot of fine uh Patriots
down there in Florida I love Florida I
love Arizona uh and I love all these
pages but that's to your point he's
really stepped out and opened up that
coffee shop knowing that he could get a
lot of pushback so what are we thinking
are we thinking things are running a
little smoother now I kind of think they
are
um the only issue is earlier when I had
the problem Chrome wasn't even running
but
okay all right good all right listen
let's let's hope that this is okay let
me actually get to some super chats here
and and talk to some people
um and see what we've got sir it might
be antifa messing with your setup I know
I know Katia says sending another Super
Chat just to thank you for saying my
name correctly thank you Jeffrey says
have you tried turning it off and back
on again I didn't do that should I shut
the Entire Computer off in the middle of
the stream and turn it back on that
could help
maybe that that would help us I want to
say oh my goodness I've missed all these
people fandastis Jen here
as well as a gift from each of them as
well as Laura Lee Alice maravillas heyo
Cindy just signed up via twitch so did
canned caviar Juan propin
devoff bar Sam the sleaze brat bag
dranoa
for 20 months Dragon daughter
Beth Graham hack fui chronotus cold
pressed juice box all have signed up
that puts us at 14 for today
and we also have an exclusive and
explosive coupon code today dystopian
rally because that's what we're about to
see you're watching today for the first
time or not the first time either way
you can use the coupon code dystopian
rally to sign up at joinpakman.com
um Miriam lockerer just signed up second
person ever to use that code and Chuck
white using the code dystopian rally
putting us at 16 the code works well
at joinpakman.com
it's arguably the best code that we've
had so you have two options today as far
as codes go you can use the code
rsbn to save 66 off of mic pillows
or or
um
you can use the coupon code dystopian
rally and save 70 off of one of my uh
off one of my memberships okay people
now saying let's try putting super chats
back on screen let's try it okay the the
next problem I was having that it was
not properly picking up window capture
was not properly picking up
um the Firefox window
okay so let's try that now
uh we're gonna do a window capture
we're going to call it a new window new
super chats
new super chats
see it's that the problem is it's
getting confused between the two windows
yeah
because now see the problem is now that
I have multiple firefoxes open
it's not realizing I have two different
ones
and one of them is the one that's
supposed to be the one with the super
chats
any ideas on that I mean I'd love to put
them up on the screen
open Chrome just for super chats
okay
is that really a good idea
I think the illegal discount code is
forcing people to shut me down yeah I
don't I don't know that I should open
Chrome
is there some Ultra lightweight browser
that I could open that I could download
I'd be willing to I'd be willing to do
that yeah no no Edge for me thank you
Duck Duck Go that's that's not a that's
not a browser is it
I don't think that's a browser
Opera
Brave or Opera
let's try the brave browser
see if it'll work we'll uh will stream
Labs pick that up as anybody know
that would be great
foreign
let's see if this works why not
this could be the end of the stream yeah
this is risky I'm not going to lie this
is pretty risky stuff
Brave is based on Chrome that doesn't
sound good if that's the problem we're
having
yeah president Donald Trump rally I know
I believe me guys I know how insane that
is trust me
I know how insane that is
all right we're gonna try to get the
super chats up let's see what we got
bear with me here
very very strong typing
all right let's give it a shot here if
this works I will I will owe a beer to
the uh to live chat
I've got to verify some of these
elements
let's resend
yeah I might have to gift a few thousand
Subs
just kind of got to get verified here
don't know why I'm not getting my uh
authentication here
we'll give it a moment
it is absolutely insane that they just
say
president Trump as if the guy is the
president right now it it is trust me
the the irony of it and the insanity of
it is not lost on me
uh okay
president it's gross quite frankly yeah
no I agree with you
I agree with you all right here we go we
are attempting super Chats on the brave
browser
there are some really good super chats
that's why I think it would really be a
loss for the for Humanity if we were not
able to get it on the screen
we'll make sure that we're not
replicating the video here
um
no super chats how could that be all
right
so let's see
now we will add
looks like they just lost video
all right new super chats
it doesn't even show it Brave just
doesn't even show up in the list
it's really weird
it just doesn't even accept it
that's strange right
try clearing your cash
why would it be that it just doesn't
um
that it doesn't even show that's that's
really strange
a lot of people saying it should be no
problem but
there's a lot of really really dumb
suggestions but in the midst of it
there's actually like some okay ones
um
yeah no it's just it's just not liking
it for some reason I have a window open
with uh super chats
but it just doesn't
it just doesn't allow it as an option
I see it here
window capture
chat new
oh here it is hold on Brave oh stand by
folks
stand by
stand by folks
look at this
I think we've got it
imagine if I become unsynced now after
this that'd be that would be truly
horrifying
all right so let's move this back up
give ourselves a little space
all right so we're going to go all the
way to the bottom because that's usually
the way we do it and we'll just wait for
the super chats to fill up
if they eat they even do
there we go
all right sorry for closing out some
people's super chats it's just the way
it's got to be done
okay all right I think
oh no don't tell me I'm out of sync now
did I go out of sync because I did this
sync is good
okay all right good okay beautiful guys
as the super chats come in they're going
to be showing up on the screen this is
fantastic we're back in business I
believe I want to say thank you to see
mizzle for gifting 10 Subs panoman 90
Shilling Astro lycos with a gift and a
sub that's seven putting us at 23 and we
are moments away from this very strange
rally with Donald Trump let me say thank
you to Amber Peters who just signed up
on my website using the coupon code
dystopian rally Dave machavilla Marty
Cummings Zach Barnett and Tracy Guinea
um putting us at 28 as we are hopefully
I don't want to speak too soon but
hopefully starting to get in the
direction of working technology because
it's been a pretty tough stream from the
standpoint of tech
um people are asking for live twitch
captions that's nothing I'm aware of
that I can turn on I've never heard of
that it's nothing we've ever turned on
or off I'm just not aware
of that at all uh
thanks to Mako scuba for gifting five
Subs over on Twitch very much appreciate
that
um
let's see if our super chats are
starting to come in there they are oh
look at these look at these super chats
folks they're on
let me see if we've got it
there we go
okay let's go through these
in order
quite the Cyber Symposium you're having
sir yeah thank you
a lot of test super chats
all right everyone grab a bag to puke in
time for another Trump rally
s Perez just sent a 100 Super Chat and
says thought I was watching the Linus
Tech tips for the last 15 minutes I I
wish I had some of those people helping
me today I I'm telling you I sent a 10
super chat before two questions when do
you take calls Discord for the Friday
show Wednesday Wednesday we take the
calls and can you bring back the Trump
Bingo cards yeah I would I would do that
I would do that my thought is we'll
bring back Trump Bingo when we get
closer to like the midterms and Trump
doing
um rallies for people
I think that that would be great
you are synced and this should be a new
segment problem solving with pack yeah
we'll see talk about fake news president
dump GTFO
wow that guy being interviewed said the
Dems passed the law allowing post-birth
abortions of course they didn't
filling in a super chat audio is great
we did it thank you Katya Uriel says sir
former president Trump is a bigly loser
Jake says massive dumps thanks Jake
appreciate that
uh very very good
all right so we've got this and we've
got that a lot of things working well
guys a lot of things working well pink
tie looks like a bad night of drinking
yeah let's listen to what this guy's
saying
you know the thing about that is
um
right now particularly in the context of
the pandemic
Biden supporters just don't feel a big
need to gather in large numbers when
it's optional like you know if you've
got to gather in large numbers because
you've got to get a flight somewhere you
go and you do it you wear your mask
um you know if you've got to take public
transit because that's how you get to
work
you do it but the left isn't looking to
do big events right now that's number
one but number two I don't doubt that
Biden wouldn't get this amount of people
for a rally
part of that is because Biden hasn't
built a cult of personality around
himself
such that people would do this it's like
Biden's been saying hey you know what
let's all go get vaccinated and then you
go and you get vaccinated
um it's just the you know this is
because of the cult of personality
around Trump
and it doesn't really mean much about
policy to say can you imagine this big a
crowd for Joe Biden it's actually it's
very stupid
it's very very stupid
um
I miss hatred mail
cranberry Miracle David Lord sir looking
forward to Trump spending Thanksgiving
in the white house this year
um
I don't even know that I get that Trump
is banned from Twitter but rsbn is
tweeting press releases why haven't they
been suspended yeah nobody's really
getting suspended for that that's the
truth
say Mike pillow five times in your
mirror and you'll grow a mustache I'll
try that later
I'll try that later that sounds
interesting
um
yeah
okay
um Trump is 20 minutes late now so that
means he should be starting within the
next hour or so if uh history is any
judge let's listen to just a couple of
voicemails okay I want to see what's on
people's minds
hey David
pleasure
Elizabeth Holmes theranos
trial I'm watching it whoa just lost a
headphone I'm watching it very closely
the book Bad Blood by John Kerry Roo is
a fantastic non-fiction Caper about the
scam that was executed by Elizabeth
Holmes she seems to have lost her mind
but did she ever have it given what she
was willing to do and I'm watching the
trial very closely and I'm very very
interested in seeing what happens
um let's listen to another voicemail
the 14th Amendment section three present
Trump from even running again
what in the hell is wrong with our
country 14th section three I I don't
know offhand what that is
uh but I can look into that
this new multiple caller is calling in
let's listen
even sure oh no
oh no no no you know what's going on
volume master and Google Voice do not
work well together and it just repeats
let me see
David sure
oh my God these conflicts between things
all right so now we can't do voicemails
because volume Master screws around with
that but without volume Master we
wouldn't have the right amount of audio
wow it's it's just crazy what's
happening
um all right so we're not going to do
voicemails right now we've we've got to
get some of these conflicts sorted out
we really do because otherwise I don't
think uh
I don't even know that we're going to be
able to make it quite frankly if we
don't sort these out we rallied in
Alabama I love you Alabama but you were
hot humid and the ground was muddy this
weather right here is perfect 80 degrees
almost no humidity
weather reports even the weather is
perfect for Trump if you can imagine
other super chats coming in uh same okay
got that I always enjoy your interview
with amazing guests and especially
excited with the one with Pro Professor
Michael sandel it was awesome that was
great uh I've I've been following
Michael sandel for so long and it was so
great to have them on really really
great if you haven't seen that interview
check it out it's it's excellent really
really excellent
um thanks to deba
for gifting a sub on Twitch as well as
bowflexman for the 19 months very much
appreciate that we are going to be
hearing from Donald Trump momentarily he
will presumably be telling us hey you
know what guys they did the audit in
Arizona I didn't really win my bad it's
fine Joe Biden won everything's cool
just kidding obviously he's not going to
be saying that he will probably attack
the audit in some way and say we need
one
in Georgia
and that we need one elsewhere uh that's
that's my guess at this point about what
we are going to hear from Donald Trump
today we we may get some kind of signal
from him also about whether he will be
running in 2024 but I don't know I
believe this will be a completely
dystopian rally
and I would love for you to get a
membership on my website with the coupon
code dystopian rally uh this is a code
that we created today for today only
you can go to joinpakman.com this code
dystopian rally it has to be spelled
whoa sorry it has to be spelled
correctly that's the only thing if you
don't spell it right it's not going to
work
um
but a whole bunch of people taking
advantage of that coupon code and I will
thank every one of them
every single one of you would get a
thank you if you use that code let's
read a couple of other super chats
coming in
14th Section 3 prevents anyone who
participated in an Insurrection from
holding office yeah you're not going to
get Trump I mean listen I I completely
understand what you're saying
but that is not going to prevent Trump
from from running in 2024. I can assure
you uh and you know he really didn't
participate in it he certainly incited
it
but he didn't participate in it
um
he he almost like kind of tricked some
people into thinking he was going to
participate in it let's go down
Pennsylvania Avenue or whatever else the
case may be all right let's see what's
going on here no media is back
each and every one of you yes I love you
and yes I love you and I yes I love you
that's the way we have it here at right
side broadcasting network we're a little
different we're a different Bunch over
here aren't we yeah we don't really fit
in sometime for the cool kids but that's
okay yeah that's that's uh that's an
understatement that is an understatement
for sure
um
wacky wacky stuff super space sloth says
is it possible that the Cyber ninjas
verified Joe Biden's win merely to
establish credibility for a future
Declaration of fraud you know I wouldn't
put that past them morally
although they've not shown an ability to
really think ahead to that much of a
degree
which kind of makes me doubt it I have
to say
they just don't really seem able
to think ahead that much
um so maybe maybe
they'll try it but these you have to
remember these are completely amoral
people but they also are not that smart
so you know it's sort of uh six and one
half dozen of the other I guess is the
way that I would say it
we seem to be close to Trump's arrival
based on the increased security presence
and just generally people being even
more agitated than they normally are
from
remarks and his his rallies are so
strategically timed last time it was
right after Afghanistan right now it's
right after that that Biden border
crisis I can't wait to hear what he has
to say about all the trees in mark
milley
the kind the Chinese Communist
propaganda oh god
um there's analysis happening there
folks that is uh that is that is
something else I do want to say thank
you to Jennifer Wagner Jennifer just
signed up at joinpakman.com using the
code dystopian rally and Jennifer is new
member number 36 today
you can grab a membership on my website
using that very same coupon code
dystopian rally
the messages continue to come in have I
seen the debate between Charlie Kirk and
Dr Rashad rashay Richie beta no I have
not seen it
sir Lindell stated his Supreme Court
case would be heard soon and Trump would
be reinstated by Thanksgiving oh okay
Yahoo it's hard to keep up with Mike
Lindell it really is
how long before Trump wants to audit the
audit he may announce that today
he very much May
um
this rally will be the same we've been
seeing just the same catchphrases and
pot stirring like a stand-up or pro
wrestling routine
very much so I expect exactly that I
expect exactly that without without any
question whatsoever
big thank you to Nora Thompson Nora
signing up at joinpakman.com using the
coupon code dystopian rally as continues
to be the case overwhelmingly our
audience is male but membership signups
during live streams
skew very much the other direction
um
many many folks coming in positive from
the standpoint of female on the new
memberships that are coming in thanks to
Michael Williams though also Michael
Williams using the code dystopian rally
number 38 today thanks Michael very much
appreciate that
um
yet sometimes the crowd gets riled up
and Trump's not even really that close
it's just sort of like they've been here
for 12 hours and they're like he must be
here soon it doesn't it wouldn't make
sense for him not to arrive soon thanks
to Ethan Ash for signing up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
dystopian rally
thanks very much Ethan appreciate that
um
Mark is music says I'm almost positive
the music being used at that rally would
not be condoned by the musicians of
course a staple of right-wing rallies is
music from artists who are horrified at
its use all right let's see it looks
like something's happening hey Trump
[Applause]
[Music]
dear God that song they're still using
it
Jason sir David Pacman how is your
powerful Tesla doing sir still powerful
it's still the amount of it's actually
shocking the power
really really shocking I didn't even
know they could do it
uh
uh but apparently they can here's Trump
coming out
[Music]
hahaha
it's hard to find something cringier
than that song it really really is like
it's it's particularly combined with
silver spoon New Yorker you know
um it's very tough to figure out
something cringier
I want to say a huge thank you to
Desiree Delong for signing up on my
website with the coupon code dystopian
rally
um while multiple angles of trump
flapping his hands we're going to be
hearing from him very soon let's make
sure that we are in HD
um also a big thank you to Donna pity
Donna pity just signing up at
joinpakman.com coupon code dystopian
rally folks this is the day if you've
been thinking uh maybe I'll get a
membership on the David Pacman show
website maybe I'll do it
there is no better day than today we
have the coupon code dystopian rally
going it saves you
okay you use it you save
I just it's so much I can't say it
because then my accountant gets after me
my lawyer gets after me everybody gets
after me they come to me they say sir
it's too big of a discount but we're
doing it
um you can use that code today at
joinpakman.com this will be a dystopian
rally it's starting in mere moments
thanks to Emily Morgan the ladies are
just signing up they're dumping in
massive memberships today uh thanks to
Emily Morgan for signing up
it sounds criminal what people are doing
on my website I'm not gonna lie
it actually does James Montalbano says
sir is it is literally the worst song of
all time I hate this song I really do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I hate it
I hate it
wow thank you very much everybody
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody trying to
get some volume for us
hello to
hello
very slurry today already I want to
congratulate
a team that we all love the Georgia
Bulldog that was a big win
you obviously have one of the best teams
in the nation that's looking like a fact
we have one of their players from a few
years ago with us tonight thanks
Patricia and John by the way for the
memberships a special man I'm thrilled
to be back in This Magnificent state
with thousands of hard-working
God-fearing Freedom loving do you think
putting blacks for Trump always on
camera is something that is just kind of
like standard now like if you're a
Republican and there are black people
you just got to put them on camera
we have great great people running many
of them are right here hello Marjorie oh
God
with your help
your helps and sent Nancy Pelosi back to
San Francisco
well
where she can work very hard to bring
back a city which he has helped to very
so this is actually really relevant
starting to talk about we're going to
take the house remember guys I told you
uh we're gonna get we're gonna flip the
election the fraud the artists all the
stuff we're going to flip it's going to
be November December eventually it's
just going to be hey guys it's 20 it's
the midterms we got to take back the
house this seems to be the start of that
transition back our country from these
lunatics
[Music]
in just eight months Joe Biden and the
radical Democrats are well on their way
to Turning America into a third world
nation that's what's happening you see
it here as much as anybody I Told You So
during the election and during the
campaign inflation is skyrocketing
unemployment is rising at a level that
nobody can believe main streets are
being boarded up murders are through the
roof you look at what's happening at
these democrat-run cities violent gangs
are drugged out vagrants are taking over
our big cities our once great cities
corruption is rampant remember I do have
a segment outlining this idea of violent
democrat-run cities it's it's probably
you know it'll take eight to ten minutes
to straighten people out on it but it's
worth checking out that clip so you know
what to say when people mention this
stuff also I see the memberships dumping
and at this rate we're going to be at a
hundred and no time folks
[Applause]
yeah
what's interesting is blacks for Trump
sometimes only stay for part of the
rally like the last rally
it started with a lot of the blacks for
Trump Folks up behind Trump
within about 40 minutes they were gone
and like it happened very quietly it was
strange they were just gone and it led
people to speculate they are paid to be
there I have no evidence to suggest
that's the case save America we're
talking about saving remember we had
make America great again and I said oh
boy now we have to do it again because
they what they've done so we had make
America great again again
again again
we made it great now we got to make it
great again that begins with the nurse
shattering wind in November 2022 and by
the way we never forget guys they're
just going to the web to the midterms
[Applause]
here we go
followed by an even more glorious
Victory sir are you aware of what
happens in Russia's elections
[Applause]
if we have a country left in 2024 that's
the problem we're going to have a
country left what they're doing at this
level what they're doing at this level
you're not gonna have a country left
there's no greater crisis facing our
nation today than the catastrophe on our
Southern border you've been watching it
and a lot of the fake news and you got a
lot of them back look at all of those
fake newspapers
[Applause]
no new material kind of notable right
just nothing nothing new you know
you know selves no favor American
sovereignty is being extinguished by the
deliberate and willful policies put in
place by Joe Biden and the left-wing
extremist he has installed in power I
don't know if Joe is exactly involved I
don't know I don't know that's the
dementia joke but somebody's really
screwing up our country
destroying our country in Del Rio Texas
you've been watching tens of thousands
of illegal immigrants have overrun our
borders in recent days while laughing in
the faces of our border patrol agents
and they're going after the Riders of
the horses not the people that came in
illegally isn't that incredible and
they've just put them under watch
they're in big trouble the writers of
those horses
most people would say they were doing
one hell of a job right don't you
remember guys they weren't whipping
anybody because they didn't have whips
they were whipping people with reins but
okay
if I were your president and we should
have
75 million votes
when I was in the White House illegal
aliens knew that if they broke our laws
and trespass across our borders they
would be caught they would be detained
and they would be thrown out of our
country very rapidly so they didn't come
they didn't come because it was not
worth the trip and then you have to go
back it wasn't worth the trip when they
came when they made the statement come
with open arms the world is coming into
our country they're emptying them what's
funny is one of the reasons Joe Biden is
being criticized is he's deporting the
Haitians too quickly without actually
figuring out who has a valid claim for
Asylum that's that's one of the
criticisms they're emptying their
prisons
coming into our country
under my Administration we ended Catch
and Release we shut down Asylum for it
we struck historic agreements with
Mexico and Central American nations to
stop illegal immigration and we deported
dangerous criminal aliens by the tens of
thousands including MS-13
killers
we got them out by the thousands we
built almost 500 miles of powerful
border wall and it was tough because we
had to go through two and a half years
of litigation against Democrats that
were suing us including Congress we
created
the most secure Border in the history of
the United States of America
[Applause]
and the wall could have been finished in
a month they didn't want to finish the
wall this is not even believable it took
us we were building at record rates but
we had to get the approval from the
courts two and a half years of fighting
and winning 11 different cases now Joe
Biden has thrown the Border wide open
and our country is being invaded by
hundreds now you guys know like
nothing's actually changed at the border
nothing's nothing's any more wide open
other than the fact that
thanks to a period during which covet
was less bad
there was more movement taking place
like I don't even know where this stuff
comes from first of all you guys
understand according to one report 220
miles of the area near Del Rio
is now completely and completely totally
just absorbed by people but totally un
un patrolled the police are saying you
know what do we do to have this is an
invasion
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
how quickly do you guys think Trump
loses the crowd see the crowd is the
crowds are very low information and
often they don't even really know what
he's talking about so sometimes within
15 minutes he's lost the crowd sometimes
it takes longer
oh hold on what's going on to get more
money from that building than they ever
got for building you got some
contractors over here they're laughing
because they know exactly what I'm
saying don't you
Biden germinated our Asylum agreements
instituted Nationwide Catch and Release
crippled ice these are great Patriots I
was tough I wouldn't want that job that
guy with the beautiful jacket on come
here let me look at him look at that
beautiful stand up in the chair stand up
in that chair remember when Trump had a
rally yelled out where's my
African-American
that was crazy
right it's again he's been how many
rallies have you been to
oh boy he's a and he's a great guy and a
great Patriot and you know when he takes
that back off he goes into a shirt and
he probably goes back to his Accounting
Office
hey guys how can I turn off this
picture-in-picture thing that keeps
popping up here it's extremely annoying
oh there it is
great guy
T.I Chuck Todd of NBC News was recently
forced to admit that Biden's open
borders and his policies are acting as a
magnet attracting illegal aliens from
all over the planet yet despite this
obvious disaster radical Democrats and
the House and Senate continue to push
for Mass amnesty you know it's really
hard to believe they think this is good
when you look at what's happening as you
know Haiti is emptying out into our
country Haiti they have a lot of
problems in Haiti and it's very sad but
we're bringing people into our country
sounds so sincere it's just a terrible
terrible terrible situation we're living
through the worst border crisis in the
history probably of civilization there's
no border nobody has a border like this
we don't do anything you know other
countries even if they're not well
equipped they put up a fight they don't
let people come in we're just letting
them just walk right in and your own
Senator Raphael Warnock
uh-oh
is not uttered a single solitary word of
criticism
the Marxist controlled by the radical
left Democrats who don't believe in
borders and they don't
believe in a nation and they don't
believe in our nation I don't believe
they believe in our nation next year
Warnock and every single one of these
far left lunatics must be routinely and
resoundingly and decisively defeated
they have to be defeated you're not
going to have a country left
if you want to have a country left you
must elect no Democrats and vote only
for America it seems the headline here
is Trump voter fraud claims in shambles
as he moved goals moves goal posts to
2022 right I mean that's how I would
summarize this so far different make
America great again we'll never give
that one up right make America great
again I thought we could sort of put it
aside for a while right but as soon as
they came in we said we need that one
again but we have some good ones but
when you think about it some of those
phrases is so they're so on they're so
perfect some of the first think about
make America great again save America
America First think of it America first
and I'll never forget when Biden first
came into office if you can believe this
he said we don't believe in America
First policies I said you know even if
you really don't you can't say that it
doesn't work he doesn't believe but it's
true they don't believe in America first
they don't believe in America First
policies the world is eating our lunch
They're laughing at us they watch what
happened in Afghanistan and they think
we're weak and stupid and I'll tell you
when I was President they respected us
they respected destruction I don't
remember that I really don't because
they were ripping us off and we stopped
it we stopped it and we'll go into it
too for the last eight months Biden
Pelosi and the Socialist Democrats have
been relentlessly
pushing the demented lie that their
political opponents are the number one
threat think of it the number one threat
to National Security they call them the
Trump people you know what that is that
75 million people but it's really much
more than that much much more than that
how Sarah
and that's the largest vote by far ever
gotten by a sitting president no
president has ever come close to it
and most presidents go down in the
second term even if they win they go
down Obama went down way down but he won
well I don't know maybe he won who the
hell knows everyone
nowadays with these elections who knows
everyone but he went down a lot
and he won most of them go down some of
them go up but if they go up they don't
go up much we went up by 12 million
votes I was told sir a great post so we
got 63 million he said sir if you go up
one million votes you can't lose sir
well we went up 12 million votes and
they say we lost
but there never has been
you know there never has been a
concession you do know that right
oh Trump's saying he hasn't conceded
right
When Stacy
says I'm not going to concede it's okay
no
When Stacy Abrams says I'm not going to
concede that's okay no problem oh she's
not going to concede she's not going to
concede
of course having her I think might be
better than having your existing
Governor if you want to know before
might might very well be better but when
she says that no problem when crooked
Hillary Clinton says don't ever concede
but she conceded of course I got her at
three o'clock in the morning there was
something going on
[Applause]
but she conceded uh she probably regrets
it but I never conceded because I saw
what was happening and I can't do it I
can't do it because I have a commitment
to you and I can't do it
and
honestly it would have been a lot easier
for me if I did like every politician uh
I'd like to congratulate sleepy Joe in a
running a brilliant race from the
basement
somebody ran a good race we don't know
who the hell it was it was and when
somebody ran a good race but the fact is
that we ran a great race a major Media
Group came and they interviewed me two
weeks ago they go sir what was the
difference between 2016. it can't be in
2020. it meant that like as a negative
question I said well let me tell you the
difference we did much better in 2020
than we did in 2016.
we did much better
the rallies were bigger they were more
enthusiastic we did much much better we
got 12 million more votes I mean we went
from 63 to 75 million congratulations so
I said and the person said you know I
never thought of that I never he wasn't
that bad he was Radical left but he
wasn't that bad but he did say
I followed your campaign it was the most
incredible campaign I've ever witnessed
where
foreign
do you guys think that really happened
and five of these rallies a day and you
did that for 30 days before the election
he said I've never seen anything like
that and he said there has never been
anything like that in the history of
politics in this country and probably in
the history of politics in the world
there's never been a movement like this
I said are you going to write that he
said probably not
he said probably not and and the reason
not is his bosses probably would let him
write that but there has never been a
movement like a mega movement like this
there's never been anything never been
but they said what's the difference and
I said we did better in 2020 Joe Biden
is not merely a threat to our national
Securities actively demolishing it
before our very eyes Biden triggered
millions of illegal aliens to rush our
borders in the middle of a global
pandemic in the middle of the pandemic
where's your mask where's your mask now
the pandemic is serious I guess where's
your man
[Applause]
where's that mandate
why aren't they imposing a mandate I
mean they oppose a mandate on everybody
but not the people coming in
in Afghanistan he humiliated our nation
with the most appalling display of
incompetence by an American president
in history
13 great young warriors were murdered
and many injured and a total of 170
people were killed with many very very
badly wounded
in their memory tonight we have 13 empty
seats of Honor oh no right here in the
front row hey guys
I wasn't lying when I said dystopian
rally huh
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're also honored to be joined by
one of the Marines who bravely served
in Kabul during the withdrawal and
helped evacuate children over the
airport and over the airport wall you
saw him he did a great job Lance
corporal hunter in Clark lance corporal
come up here
this is as dystopian as I imagined
um we're going to listen to what this
guy says
um I I do see all the memberships coming
in on the website I apologize I can't
keep up with all the names because so
much is going on but thanks to the 71
folks the code is dystopian rally at
joinpakman.com also thanks to everybody
supporting via twitch look at this
[Applause]
hey my name's uh Lance corporal Hunter
Clark I'm here from uh Warner Robins
Georgia
uh
I am the guy that uh pulled the baby
over the wall and it's definitely
probably one of the greatest things I've
ever done in my entire life
I actually don't know what he's talking
about
I just want to thank all the support
from all y'alls really means a lot and
uh I'm glad to be home now today thank
you
[Music]
he pulled a baby over the wall
[Applause]
foreign
thank you Hunter very much I appreciate
it thank you very much thank you hey you
know Perry Georgia did a good job
they did a good job you grow them well
in Perry Georgia Biden surrendered our
Forts and Air Base in Bagram you know we
were going to keep the air base because
it's right right next to China oh God
and their military institutions and
their installations and they have a lot
of things surrounding it and we had this
big beautiful Air Base that caused
billions of dollars to build and we were
gone we didn't even turn out the lights
and one day we were gone and you know
who's looking at it now and who's all
over it
we were never leaving that we had a
perfect plan and they were listening to
us Abdul Abdul you can't shoot our
soldiers you know what for 18 months we
didn't have one soldier killed they
listened to me I said you can't do it
I'll do it will hit you harder than
you've ever been hit you can't do it
and he understood that and he left us
alone and we would have never moved our
military out first we would have never
they would have gone last first
Americans then our people deserve to
come out of which by the way the people
that came out are not the ones that they
were talking about that was just like a
mad rush but uh Abdul understood that he
was not going to do anything to us and
we would have taken our soul remember
this whole thing with Abdul it's not
clear anyone he was dealing with was
named Abdul for a while he would refer
to him as Muhammad but we don't we don't
really know that that's the person's
name and it would have been so good but
this guy they just took the military out
first that's like the captain or the
ship much more severe by the way if a
captain of a ship goes you say all right
he didn't have guts
but it's not going to affect it too much
they took the military out first
and that's why you have those 13 empty
seats right there that's why because
they took the military out first and
they created a void and the Taliban said
what's going on I can just see Abdul
he gets a call or a message it said the
military has left
he said you're nuts in their language
you there's no way
sir the military is left
they've abandoned they've surrendered
they've quit whatever the hell he said
and I guarantee he said there's no way
that happened nobody could be that
stupid they're smart you know they're
good Fighters
the Taliban the Afghans generally are
very good Fighters very good among the
best actually and they said no no he did
and they sent a group in
and they said you know what the military
is not there anymore that's why we had
to bring people in that weren't even
familiar with all of it they weren't
they brought those 13 great people and
many that are wounded very seriously
what is he talking about
among others
they moved this Millie is an idiot I got
to know him he's an idiot
okay they moved the military out first
let's get the military out
and then after
that for hostages okay and let's leave
them 85 billion dollars in America's
Finest weapons and latest equipment
and he abandoned hundreds of American
citizens in enemy occupied territory and
the Press is trying to play the whole
situation down like it never took place
because they are among the most corrupt
people in this country
you don't even see it anymore about
Afghanistan they don't talk about it
they don't talk about it but I will
the Democrats are after me with
prosecutors and everything else I see
people saying he's losing the crowd he's
actually keeping the crowd longer than
normal like I'm surprised the crowd is
still this with him
they want to silence me just like
they've silenced so many others it's one
of the reasons we don't get the support
we should from a lot of very good
Republicans but they're not as Brave as
they have to be and others are
in agreement with us but they're afraid
the people we're dealing with are evil
and angry and destroying our country
they're destroying our country
and they want to go after me because I
have they think a big mouth I don't have
a big mouth you know what I have I have
something about this woman's facial
expressions really really bothering me
also can what is this
is
is this appropriate right here what what
the hell is this
now Biden is bringing into the United
States tens of thousands of unvetted
unscreened Afghan Nationals that's
insane right
like does it matter whether these folks
are even Asian
what the hell I can't believe I just
noticed that and I think there's a
couple of them and we're going to
resettle them I guess with a child bride
are they doing that with the child Brian
a lot of those people that rushed the
planes are not the people that worked
with us they're people that wanted to
get out you're going to see some bad
things happen over the coming years it's
a disgrace in just the last few days one
Afghan National arriving in our country
has been charged with sexually
assaulting a child another with
strangling and beating his wife and in
New Mexico a great great place by the
way a group of male Afghan evacuees
reportedly ganged up on a female
American Service member and brutally
assaulted her
ask Germany how are they doing
they're not too happy ask Sweden how are
they doing they want to tell you the
nice liberal way but it's not working
out too well Biden terminated our very
hard Fort floor travel ban you remember
the travel ban like we don't want this
is this is pretty bad destroy us okay
you know it's pretty simple
on terrorists occupied countries that we
went through the entire system to defend
and won in the Supreme Court of the
United States this travel ban went on
for two years of litigation and I ended
up winning in the Supreme Court of the
United States it was very tough because
all it says is people that want to blow
up our stores
and blow up our streets in our cities
people that want to hurt people people
that don't love our country we don't
want you in the United States that's the
travel ban
and Biden is drastically increasing the
number of so-called refugees who would
be resettled in America and all over
American communities all over next year
he's expanding that number
but the travel ban was so strong it was
so good when a country was angry at us
when they were bad when they had people
that wanted to blow our streets up and
our stores up and set stores on fire and
set our cities burning we had a travel
ban we said no thank you you can keep
them we're not letting them in
he is now officially ended the travel
ban it's a disgrace he's doing nothing
to hold the Chinese Communist I know you
guys know this but just in case anybody
forgot that travel ban was basically
countries that we had no reason to
believe were sort of like a source
country for terrorists coming to the U.S
and doing things like even on principle
it didn't make sense but the facts also
didn't make any sense and our country
and by the way for his poll numbers
which have tanked in short after just
eight months Joe Biden is already the
biggest failure ever to occupy
the Oval Office and I can think of a
couple of people
I'll tell you what
Jimmy Carter is extremely happy right
now
so is another president but I won't
mention his name because there might be
there might be about three people here
that thought he was okay
this is what happens when you
dishonest election this is all about a
rigged election
none of these disease never should have
been allowed to happen last week it was
painstakingly revealed
by Durham you know Durham the Durham
repo thank you thank you Durham thank
you Mr Durham we've been waiting but he
came out with a big one and perhaps
they're going to come out with a lot
more because it was a pretty big
the Durham investigators at the Russia
Russia Russia hoax was indeed a total
scam
made up by crooked Hillary Clinton and
the Democrats how would you like to have
her as you guys it's almost 2022 he's
talking about crooked Hillary
foreign
[Applause]
no but think of this I mean Bill Clinton
he's living in fear
he's living in fear now think about an
evil mind like that to make up a Russia
hoax you know I'll tell you a quick
little story should I or should I just
go through it
you know they came to me they said sir
no it's just sort of crazy I kept
hearing the word like Russia because
during my campaign before you heard
about the so-called Russia hoax
people would come up with me and they'd
say sir I can't pay people sure do you
ever hear anything about Russia
and I said no not really I mean Russia
is Russia right they're ripping us off
just like every other country in the
world now by the way they're really
ripping us because of what they've done
with energy they're making a fortune
because of my I ended the pipeline and
he approved it but he knocked out the
Keystone didn't he huh but they say Sir
an innocent young great people they love
our country sir
another one coming up a couple of months
left sir did you ever hear anything do
anything about Russia
no then a third one comes up a month
later sure
have anything to do with Russia this is
too much no
after about four or five times you know
the way it is I said what the hell is
going on with Russia
and that's what's going on with Russia
they made up a hoax and we had to live
with it for three years what kind of a
sick perverted mind does that and it was
the lawyer and Hillary Clinton and the
devil is it just me or are one or two of
the blacks for Trump people gone already
six okay they're doing it again
they're doing it again we went through
three years of Hell battling this fake
charge
that was only allowed to happen because
the media was complicit as they always
are for the Democrats
and it was totally criminal what took
place I think you'll be seeing a lot of
things about but this I
it is officially now
a hoax most of you knew that from the
beginning
and you see this guy Shifty shift Adam
Shifty shift president Trump
is a paid worker for Russia I said what
the hell do I have to do with Russia
Adam Shifty shift and now he's doing it
again the same guy the same face that
same watermelon shaped face
does kids for Trump count as child abuse
would you guys say
be disappointed about that but the same
guy that would get up at a microphone
and say president Trump's son is
involved with Russia I'd call Don do you
have anything to do with Russia he
didn't know what the hell he was talking
he thought it was crazy Eric and these
are good kids they work their asses off
for the country I want to tell you
what a shame these kids we went through
it
and then it was a total hook so we knew
it
anyway
none of this is I I I'm not interrupting
because people get mad but just remind
me in the chat that you guys know this
is not true right that the stuff he's
saying is all a lie
stories thank goodness
and the lawyers for the Democrat Party
Michael Sussman
he was he was just fired and he was
he was just fired
and arrested
for what he did
and you have another one
Mark Elias
he's no longer with Perkins koi which is
the big Law Firm that the Democrats I
guess they probably got him the hell out
of there because it was getting too hot
it's a disgrace and let me tell you
something
just like they tried
on the 2016 election with a totally
fabricated con job what they did in 2020
was far worse
far worse
and much more con job that's uh c h e a
n
j h e a b
complicated more highly sophisticated
they worked on
and we were given a few weeks to find
out what they did we knew it was fake we
knew what they were doing but we were
given a very small part of time we
didn't get any help from Mitch McConnell
we didn't get any help from that guy
they attacked and cheated on our
elections and they did it right here in
Georgia also right here in Georgia
now the people of Georgia must replace
the rhinos and weak Republicans who made
it all possible
in particular your incompetent and
strange I had something wrong with this
guy your secretary of state
[Applause]
I'm telling you I think there's
something wrong with him
and we give him so much could you look
at this could you look at that election
Integrity could you and sometimes
yesterday I'm going to look at nothing
ever happens rathensburg is something
really strange with him
yeah he wasn't willing to just give you
the state longer running
before Brian Kemp who's been a complete
disaster on election and doing their own
Republican Governor that's interesting
and I'm not looking to say that
I'm not looking to say that he's been a
complete and total disaster on Election
integrity
if you go in with a complaint about
election Integrity you get investigated
instead of investigating a crooked
election it's the craziest
well you did try to steal it for the
story I was called by a very good friend
of mine who happens to be here tonight
sir could you please endorse I think
we're 148 and two with endorsements they
like my endorsement it's never happened
before that's not true Sarah could you
please and doors
Brian Kemp I said who the hell is Brian
Kemp this is at the beginning there were
four or five I think it's five but there
were five guys five people running five
men were running
and he was in last place doing poorly
and I made the mistake
I I listened to this gentleman who's a
great guy actually and I said uh how
well do you know him
well did he ever say anything bad about
just so people know the video feed their
video feed has been having issues here
I'm trying to get us re-synced
um it is not on my end
maybe we have to do a refresh here
it's been persistently problematic
now my ad blocker not even working
hold on a 53 Oh I thought it wasn't
going to let me skip Even This Is Wild
yeah he said sir we had I guess two
rallies one had 52 000 people one had 49
000 people the big monster rallies at
the airport all your Master's not even
working
and they weren't there for him they were
there for me
and the hell
Stacy Abrams who still has not conceded
and that's okay Stacy would you like to
take his place it's okay with me
she still has not conceded
but we had
but we had just so you understand we had
the most incredible rallies the most
incredible rallies and I said Brian
you're going to win oh I don't think so
no you're going to win I'm telling you
and he ended up winning by like two
points right
and then when I called them about
election Integrity it's like I'm sorry
sir I can't do that
I said no no
no
yeah actually it was very interesting I
called uh it was weird nobody I asked to
break the law did it in a material way
this election as you obviously though
and has been
by other than the fake news has been
covered pretty pretty good but if these
guys would come back young guys sir uh
we spoke to Governor Kemp Siri will not
do anything on Election Integrity I said
no you can't don't just call him again
no I mean maybe he never got the message
they come back the next day sure
Governor Kemp won't do anything on
Election Integrity remember we wanted to
call a special election so that we could
go Marjorie so we could go into election
Integrity what is wrong with that right
and he said no we were and I think the
governor is the only one that can call
it right and he wouldn't do it he
wouldn't do it so when these guys are
young and nice guys they came back they
said he won't do it so I said let me
handle it this is easy
you know I got this guy elected one
thing has nothing to do with is he gonna
brag about calling and demanding 11 000
votes now also why is the lectern
lopsided Ukraine deal the fake Ukraine
we had Russia Russia Russia Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine they were both fake
deals okay I got impeached twice on fake
news
but I said to these young people let me
handle it I was going to show them how
good I am he's quickly losing this guy
this guy is very uninterested it seems
now you have a big election Integrity
problem in Georgia
I hope you can help us out and call a
special election and let's get to the
bottom of it for the good of the country
let's get to the bottom of it for the
good of your state wait is Trump
admitting he will he wanted a new
election now sir I'm sorry I I cannot do
that this whoa I said you cannot do that
and that's why uh let me tell you this
guy's a disaster he's a disaster they
ignore and and you know I just he's been
a real a real horrible
I I could have anybody else you have
another bad one by the way you have
another bad one Ducey in Arizona he's
another Beauty
as what you have here not as bad they
ignored Monumental evidence of rampant
fraud
we've all seen the video of ballots
being pulled out from under the tables
after kicking out all of The Observers
remember that they were reportedly
curing ballots
major water main break clean out right
water main breaks had never happened
remember they said water main break
everybody get out and then sir they
smoked ballots in Hickory
but supposedly
the vote counting to be shut down for
hours and hours so everyone was out
except for these people that were on
tape
in addition Brian kept raffensberger
and your state leaders surrendered to
Stacey Abrams they totally surrendered
to her you know I think he's afraid of
Stacey Abrams I don't understand that
Stacy
they apparently dry rubbed the ballots
and cooked them in the Jamaican Jerk
style and Trump found it culturally
insensitive fantastic and he was
interviewing was a very soft interview
in this case but she's fantastic
and
I don't say he's a man Trump only
accepts ballots that have been processed
with compound butter
and she said what position do you play
I'm an offensive tackle in high school
now even in high school he was not an
offensive tackle okay and somehow I
remembered that I don't know why
about sir
he's not an offensive tackle but your
state leaders surrendered to Stacey
Abrams and allowed themselves to be
bullied into a disastrous consent decree
that Trump found the amount of
mayonnaise used in the meals for ballot
counters in Michigan suspicious but
but the legislators under here right now
but they didn't want to do anything
about it and the agreement was never
approved by the state legislature anyway
it wasn't even approved just recently it
was reported
your state this isn't Arizona now this
is the great state of Georgia
it was reported that 43 000 absentee
ballot votes were counted it's funny how
he has to clarify which state he's lying
about so that the people can get the
lies straight like wait are we supposed
to tell this lie about Arizona or that
lie that
decided by only Allah 11 000 and
770. okay he's breathing
one more more votes than that to win the
election
but we have many many more votes than we
needed to win the election I recently
sent the Georgia Secretary of State a
letter outlining the glaring issue and
I've never gotten a response
oh I had somebody said they're looking
at me for questioning the election
that'll be an interesting one let's go
after Trump because he's questioning the
election you know what
if I won or lost all I want is a fair
election that's all you want
but I have no doubt that we won and we
won big
no evidence but
and these come from the state they told
me it's funny that he's not talking
about the Arizona numbers all of a
sudden we apologize if they're not
sure who Moved more than 30 days before
the November election to a different
County in Georgia but failed to
re-register and vote in their current
County of residence that means their
votes don't count now remember
as long as they didn't go to the new
County and vote again which there's no
evidence of
it doesn't change the results no that's
a little bit of a problem there are
eighteen thousand three hundred and
twenty five individuals in Georgia who
voted whose addresses are recorded on
the U.S Postal Service says vacant
they're vacant it's extraordinarily
common that the Postal Services records
are simply not right I've dealt with
that issue myself not proof of any fraud
exclusively Fair
Joe Biden ballot images obtained through
a public records request revealed
duplicated votes which included at least
3
390 extra votes for Joe Biden in Fulton
County is everything okay is something
weird going on did someone faint
because something very strange is
happening here do you guys see what's
going on in the background Georgia
Mark Zuckerberg work to fund election
related activities
[Applause]
well they should be looking at that and
what what is that all about over 90
percent of this funding they seem to be
Fanning someone who maybe has collapsed
Trump seems oblivious to it that area is
[Music]
what's that all about you know they have
a limit of like five thousand two
hundred dollars he's given millions and
millions of dollars I don't know guys
maybe this rally was a bad idea
that's for the famous drop boxes that
you hear about where a vast percentage
of the votes in the unlocked and
unguarded boxes were for Biden they were
forbiden even though
we know who most of them were for
according to
true the vote great group at least seven
percent of the Dropbox is the woman
illegally trafficked I feel like this
woman was down 2 000 votes oh she's got
water
yeah
metropolitan area alone that's 92 000.
remember we're talking about a little
more than 11. someone's 92 000 that's
one of many categories in addition that
woman's complexion seems problematic she
seems like she could have just fainted I
can't tell alleges a gigantic illegal
ballot harvesting operation involving
large numbers it's this woman right here
is that what people are saying
with all of these discrepancies and
criminal acts Governor Kemp and
raffensberger and your attorney general
who unfortunately has not decided to get
involved other than looking at people
that are questioning the votes aren't
interested in the people that committed
the voter fraud they're only interested
in me and others because I bring voter
fraud to the Forefront in order to save
our nation from corrupt elections and to
make sure that this okay now there's an
em now those EMTs again and never
happens again
even the Fulton County D.A district
attorney is after me but no one is
willing to give us the information we
want in Fulton County and you know
Fulton County has a terrible
reputation for voter corruption probably
among the worst in the country
they say I'm being aggressive but you
have to be aggressive to weed out this
heart the Optics of the fact that Trump
is totally oblivious to it somehow makes
it even more depraved to not after me
thereafter you I just happen to be in
the way that's what's really happened
yesterday they're helping the woman out
I guess of the hour
[Applause]
's people right back there in the
headlines off she goes claiming that
Biden won
now Trump going into the Arizona artist
stuff that Biden won our fake
a very big
they like to you ever notice when they
write about that they would say while
the election results are a big lie every
reporter it's like it's like it's just
total misinformation while they're
totally unfounded everything's unfounded
big lie not correct while Trump has no
reason to say this I mean we got piles
and piles of information
affidavits by the thousands and
thousands it's a disgrace we won
on the Arizona forensic audit yesterday
at a level that you wouldn't believe and
uh what I'm going to do is I'm going to
read off for you I'm going to read off
for you their results right from their
page I'm going to read the names of
everybody who voted me in this country
yet it's so difficult because the
Washington Post the New York Times and
virtually every mainstream media Source
CNN forget it they're so dishonest
by the way their ratings are down 81
would you say that so I guess Trump is
going to claim that the reporting on the
audit is just false I I do appreciate
let me just do a one-time thank you
everybody who's been signing up using
this code dystopian rally very very
apropos of what's going on today I
really appreciate it I can't thank
everybody individually right now but you
will be thanked eventually dystopian
rally at joinpakman.com that's funny
these people aren't funny sick
there's nothing funny about it but we
have you have a cable person beating all
these guys with all that money I hope
Fox is going to pay Greg what they're
making added up together that's what I
did on The Apprentice I said I have
higher ratings than all these big stars
on The Apprentice I said to NBC at the
time they loved me so much during The
Apprentice the audience really relating
with Trump getting paid Millions because
of a negotiation he did another three
years another five we'll do whatever
they did not want me to run they said
you won't win why would you give up a
prime time show that's doing so well
and then I did it and look what happened
my life was so simple
my life was so simple I should I suggest
but you know what
what we've done is so important what
we've exposed is so important and what
we're doing and what we're going to do
is going to be the most important of all
okay
things still haven't really calmed down
a couple people just walked out
um and there's just a very strange
energy here
[Applause]
Biden wins in Arizona when they know
it's not true
he didn't win in Arizona he lost in
Arizona based on the forensic audit and
some people say and and I understand
this and I have great great friends that
really want what's best for us yeah they
say Sir you're leading in every poll by
numbers like nobody's ever seen before
think to the Future not to the past and
I say if we don't think about the past
you'll never win again in the future
because it's all rigged it's all real I
understand what they say but it's all
red
and it's a massive disinformation
campaign by the corrupt and very fake
media it's a disinformation so here's
what they say
here's what they say you ready this is
from the report how do we look up there
okay that's not bad oh this should be
good
[Applause]
[Music]
screen who the hell else gives you a
screen like that
so here's from the report okay this is
from the forensic audit by very
respected people and it was a very very
conservatively done report it's much
worse than this
the astounding findings include ready 23
344 mail-in ballots were counted despite
the person no longer living
in that address oh that's good okay
those are the address they've mailed in
but there's nobody living there as long
as they didn't vote twice it's okay
imagine in the state was only ten
thousand four hundred and fifty Seven
votes so remember this people move all
the time you know think about every
month how many people move
so you have ten thousand little over ten
thousand votes that I quote lost by how
many of them no longer live in the state
seventeen thousand three hundred and
twenty two duplicate ballots
which
we now
Francis Dr Shiva identified as having oh
Dr shiv is out of his mind it was over
between doctor look up Dr Shiva one of
the craziest people I've ever even heard
of it's you know what a duplicate is
right oh how did that happen 96 of the
ballots that came in on two of these
days were duplicates
there were 2
382 votes who voted in person even
though they had moved out
of the county
oh did they vote twice though had moved
out of the state they're not allowed to
vote but they voted anyway
5047 people remember a little over ten
thousand
eleven think of that I mean just give
that a little thought every one of these
numbers 5047 people voted in more than
one County resulting in up to
5295 what they call overvotes it's an
over vote now hold on a second
if that if 5 000 people really voted
twice
anyway
oops I made it that was my mistakes
Maricopa County's official canvas
recorded 3
432 more ballots cast than people they
recorded as having cast a vote that's
that is untrue
277 precincts have more ballot casts
than people so they have more ballots
cast
then they have people resulting in at
least 1
551 excess votes
9041 mail-in votes
and voters
well just to be executive you know what
we have to get this exactly accurate
because the fake news will say he said
votes instead of Voters
9041 mail-in voters returned more
ballots
than they were sent oh that's
interesting that doesn't even make sense
because they they photocopied ballots
that's crazy it was done by a very
respected group the videos from 255
326 remember you're talking about a
little over ten thousand votes
255 thousand
326 early votes do not have a
corresponding record in the County's
voter file oh that's interesting I don't
even know what that means that's a
record in the voter like could that just
mean it was their first time voting
that's such that's so vague is to be
meaningless we're missing this is from
their report I didn't write this report
this is findings they call it findings
and then the fake news said that I lost
we lost by a little over ten thousand
hundreds of thousands of votes we're
talking about all of this was found
without being given access to the
routers which county officials
ruthlessly withheld they didn't want to
give those routers under any
circumstances they had a between the
woman fainting and Trump going into
stats and by the way the video is just
Frozen it's freezing on its own I'm not
pausing it he's losing the crowd yeah of
Arizona and the governor Ducey was
horrible he was missing in action he was
actually against it nonetheless the
Auditors discovered that millions of
election-related files were deleted
during and after the election in
violation of federal law including a
purge of the election management system
that's a quote election management
system software the day before it began
so the audit's gonna now begin they went
to court the same guy that I guess got
fired something happened to him Elias he
went to they sent in 107 lawyers to
fight us on this to fight the people to
fight the Senate 107 oh she said 170
that could be right all these lawyers
maybe someone in the crowd has better
numbers than Trump who knows all the
court cases and the Senate hung in and
they won in addition another effort led
by Patriot Liz Harris the Maricopa
County canvassing results for Arizona
were just published where is Liz Harris
here no way why do you like Liz Harrison
how what the hell do you know about Liz
ah she's a patriot
Biden supposedly won the State of
Arizona by 10
457 roads yet
the report shows
173 104 lost votes and 96
389 ghost votes you know what a ghost
vote is right where is it where is it
it's Casper
Harris stated that a conservative
estimate of votes impacted was
299 thousand four hundred remember the
other thing also is even if these
numbers made sense and were accurate you
would then have to prove that the Gap by
which they helped Biden relative to
Trump would have even flipped like
that's four layers deep and of course
he's not mentioned anything any of that
I speak you've sort of heard before
right
regarding ghost votes Maricopa County
recorded an estimated 96
000 mail-in votes that could not have
been physically cast by the voter that
the vote was registered to could not
have been done by the voter that it was
registered to why 96. what does that
mean that's nine times more that I need
right there that's just one little
category
and the media aren't reporting this
stuff they're saying that
the election results are fine
it's
it's going it's just not acceptable
right
just like they don't want to talk about
Afghanistan
or Hunter Biden's corruption
that's the other thing came out today
you see that
They delayed the hunter Biden corruption
because they didn't want it to hurt Joe
just a reminder it's their feed that's
freezing the audio continues but the
video is choppy your president our
country has gone to hell
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's gotten depressing
big thanks to Teresa Christensen for the
new membership on our website also
Amanda Taylor
love it the new coupon code for today
only is dystopian rally and you can tell
why right I mean
it's pretty obvious
[Applause]
also thanks to Gregory Stefan who I was
not able to thank earlier
Keith urbanowicz you remember
Elaine Borghese and I love you too
you're incredible people thank you
and they're trying to take our country
away and they're trying to steal our
country and they're going to ruin our
country they're really not and once it's
destroyed remember I used to say
we will not become Venezuela this is
what's happening well I hope now this is
what's happening you take a look at
Venezuela they can't get water they
can't get anything they're living in
hell
we will not be a socialist country how
many times have I said it this is really
the issue at him this is going to be
Venezuela very soon if they keep going
the way they're going and this is all
done in a period of less than nine
months think of it this destruction of
our border all of the destruction our
military in Retreat we've never had a
military retreated before what I mean
why would you leave 83 or 85 billion
dollars worth of equipment why would you
leave brand new Blackhawk helicopters
the greatest
machine
why would you leave millions and
millions why as an example there was no
reason we had it so under control we
were getting the hell out of there but
everybody would have come out we would
have then taken the equipment I even
gave an expression I want every screw
every bolt every nail I want the tents
that the equipment is how I want
everything
Millie said to me one time I'll never
forget it sir it's more expensive
it's more expensive sir to take the
equipment than to leave it I said really
you mean you have a 10 million dollar
tank you put it on a plane and that's
more expensive than leaving it
he said it's more expensive and I never
forgot that say because that's probably
the first time I realized that he was
stupid
but you know what I did say I said
so we have brand new aircraft just out
of the factory and it's sitting on the
runways and our soldiers are fleeing and
surrendering to guys with knives good
Fighters by the way but guys with knives
that I got along with very well they
understood they're not gonna
screw around I almost use the f word and
you know
it would have been more effective if I
did but they would have he used a
horrible word so I didn't do it remember
I didn't do it
would have been so much more effective
if I used it
[Applause]
maybe later on
but
but with Millie and with all these
people they flee I said why wouldn't you
have brought in 200 Pilots 200 we have
the best pilots in the world we have the
best soldiers in the world we have the
best military in the world I rebuilt the
military
space force don't forget space I rebuilt
so why wouldn't you bring
[Music]
us don't forget first of all you
shouldn't have left anything behind so I
don't even like this idea but assuming
they really wanted to leave it behind
because they're stupid why wouldn't you
bring over 200 Pilots just take the
planes and fly them to Pakistan and then
you bring them over or fly them to some
other country of which we give them all
so much money that they all treat as
well okay you know we we get ripped off
by everybody but why wouldn't you fly
the planes out instead they leave the
planes and then they said because they
were so embarrassed because they
probably didn't even know what they were
doing they had no idea what they were
doing they said no well uh we disabled
it you know they did they let the air
out of a couple of tires of one point
these guys have the best equipment
anywhere in the world they're probably
the best armed Soldier
sold I can see at night better than I
can at 12 o'clock in the afternoon with
the sun that's how good they are better
than our soldiers have the latest models
and they have thousands and thousands
they have hundreds of thousands of
rifles and weapons and machine guns
hundreds of we left it there and there
was no reason to leave it there we could
have taken a year two years four years
or two months to get the hell out there
was no reason we had them sew at Bay
they weren't going to play games because
they knew that if they did they were
going to get hit harder than any nation
has ever been hit at their home because
it's all about their home because they
would never hit at their home but we
know where their homes are and we were
going to hit them very hard and they
understood that that's why I told you
before 18 months we didn't have one
soldier killed and even Biden said that
it was a mistake they said he said well
I will say that no soldiers have been
killed in 18 months and there's people
screaming at them don't say that you
stupid son of a [ __ ]
former president calls current president
the son of a [ __ ] very very mature guys
you see he was supposed to add a butt
but something bad but he didn't do that
as a result of the Arizona forensic
audit 41 legislators from Across the
Nation wrote an open letter to the
American people calling for audits in
all 50 states
decertification I really got to audit
California because Trump might Trump
might have won
it is clear
in Arizona that they must decertify the
election you heard the numbers and those
responsible for wrongdoing must be held
accountable it was a corrupt election
[Applause]
and it's my opinion by the way
that Georgia is far worse it's a stupid
opinion but it is his opinion and
hopefully the Arizona attorney general a
good man will do far more for his State
than your attorney general has done for
your state because your attorney general
has not done what he's supposed to be
doing and what he's supposed to be doing
is free and clear and non-corrupt
elections and they're not doing that
we must elect strong Brave America First
leaders who will be true champions for
the people and for free fair and honest
elections and we must demand election
integrity at all costs if we don't have
borders if we don't have elections if we
don't have our military back and strong
I rebuilt the military and now look what
happens they're giving it away to the
enemy
to think 28 Apache helicopters you don't
know I hate to use the term but it's
considered I didn't want to use it
before I said machine but it's
considered the most incredible killing
machine that's a horrible term right but
it's the most incredible killing machine
when a tank scenes an Apache helicopter
the blacks for Trump guys like calling
it a killing machine so that tank
operator he gets the hell out of there
because he doesn't have a chance
they hit him with a missile right down
the middle of the gun they hit him with
a missile right down that Barrel they go
boom that goes right in from five six
seven miles away the tank shoots at him
and it's going like this and they're
waving Hello Goodbye
they take out a lot of them at a time
they got brand new ones they gotta learn
to fly them but they will it goes pow
the Chinese will teach him the Russians
will teach you we have a few of those
leaders here tonight some really great
leaders including your next secretary of
state A friend of mine somebody has done
a phenomenal job Jody Heist Jody
come here wait is this the is this the
crazy anti-gay and Jody is wrong and
it's one of the worst sex Secretary of
State America secretaries Pittsburgh who
is trying to turn
because I'm fighting for election
integrity
come on up here Jody come on this guy's
a great Congressman he didn't need oh it
is Congress and I'll say this look this
guy up one of the most vile vile
horrible people the district where they
and he said I have to do this for the
good of my state I have to do this I
have to do this for the good of my
country he told me that because to be
honest I was surprised he's a
congressman who's loved in his district
who's got no problems no election
problems they could be there forever and
he said I want to do this because what's
happened Jody's going to head up Trump's
program of flushing toilets 10 to 15
times
nobody understands the disaster of the
lack of election Integrity like the
people of Georgia and now is our hour to
take it back
we've got incredible leadership from
president Trump and we need this kind of
leadership if you need an extended
service plan on your new microwave this
is exactly the guy you should be buying
it from I guess a lifetime a greatest
fighter of our lifetime God bless you
sir thank you
whoa almost looked like Trump was going
to kiss his hand that was weird
the great man great great gentleman
it was like no Jody you had it made you
just could have stayed where you were I
don't know Jody that's what we love
about you huh he loves the state he
loves his State we're also delighted to
be joined by your next lieutenant
governor man I've known for a long time
a man who really did fight very very
hard for election integrity and he got
shut down everywhere he went they wanted
to shut him down they didn't want to
have election integrity
Bert Jones said Bert come up here Bert
's running to replace your lieutenant
governor who's not running because of
the poor job he's done especially on
Election reform and election integrity
come up there great job
[Applause]
oh God
don't y'all love this man
this man whoa
whoa he's not ready for that
I Just Want to Thank You Mr President
for all your hard work you continue to
fight for this country fight for our
state thank you so much for uh
endorsement and I can assure you if I've
been our lieutenant governor we would
have gotten to the bottom of this thing
so no doubt so thank you very much what
he means is I would have given you the
election against the law blacks for
Trump loving this guy somehow huh
thank you very much bro great guy
he's another one he loves you and he
loves our state this state in addition
we absolutely must take back your U.S
Senate seat from the radical left
liberal
Raphael Warnock who nobody knew who the
hell he was and then
a lot of crazy things happened all of a
sudden he's a U.S senator how did that
happen
the people voted but that's why I'm
especially proud to welcome a man who
truly knows how to win the United States
of America is so proud of this man one
of the greatest athletes in our
country's history the greatest Herschel
Walker that I've ever seen
a man
who played at his
[Music]
broke every record
[Applause]
he broke every record come on up here
Herschel Walker come up here
you know her Show's not only a
Georgia hero he is an American Legend
Herschel is a Legend born and raised in
this state Herschel became one of the
greatest football players of all time
and I don't want to get in trouble but I
guarantee I watched him and he was the
greatest player that Georgia ever had
[Music]
as a Georgia Bulldog he was a three-time
All-American and a Heisman Trophy winner
before going to an outstanding career in
the NFL he was great in the NFL a lot of
interesting fact about Herschel Walker
he allegedly threatened to kill his
ex-wife which led to a protective order
uh being given to her I know he will
he was one of the greatest senators in
America so Herschel please say a few
words
thank you man
thank you very much
well I'll tell you what can you not tell
this man love the United States of
America
and I just want to thank him again for
all you've done for me not just for
endorsing me for this Senate run but
we've been together for a long time and
I said it a long time ago a great man
great leader and I want to be a leader
like him when I get to that Center seat
to show everyone I love America thank
you thank you Georgia for welcoming a
great president the greatest president I
call him the people's president so thank
you guys
okay
just sick of fancy what a guy
what a guy thank you Herschel get out
really work for him
make sure we have an honor selection too
[Applause]
thank you Herschel finally I want to
thank some of the other terrific
Republican leaders and we have some
great ones in your state I actually want
to thank good people including the 98
people that have gotten US 98 of the way
to our goal uh dystopian rally the code
works at joinpakman.com these you guys
are the real heroes not whoever Trump is
thanking David Purdue are you running
for governor David did I hear he's
running
he just lost thank you David he's a
great guy and he loves this state and
he's done a fantastic a fantastic job
another good friend of mine right
here in Perry Georgia Secretary and
former governor of your state for eight
years he was term limited or you would
have been he'd still be here wouldn't we
be happy if he was Sonny Perdue he did a
fantastic job
he did a fantastic job really horrible
they have good genes in that family
thank you sonny great job you did in the
administration we appreciate it how much
money did we get for the farmers and I
took it all out of China huh I charged
them hundreds of billions of dollars in
tariffs so we gave the farmers what 28
billion dollars and we had plenty left
over for the country but we gave the
farmers the farmers didn't know what the
hell they were doing they never got
money like this and they didn't even
want it you know I had Farmers come to
me sir we don't want subsidy she
actually said nobody said that to me
when I was President the farmers did
they said sir we just want a Level
Playing Field that's all we want it's an
amazing thing
but we gave him 28 billion dollars
anyway Sonny and you did a fantastic job
some real Warriors that fight with me on
the uh impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two and many
other things they were great
Representatives Rick Allen Rick thank
you very much great job thank you Rick
great guy too
Andrew Clyde Andrew thank you
great job thank you Andrew fantastic
people Austin Scott
hi Austin thank you
great being with you a little while ago
and a person who's very low-key
a person
who I got to know really well
a person that depressed does not treat
fairly and I will tell you right now
just in a sense she's really tough and
she's really really smart
Taylor green
becoming a cult hero it's crazy
it's actually crazy what's going on with
her
very smart
they don't like to say that do they huh
they'd always see as smart as hell not
particularly bright she knows what's
going on thank you Marjorie and you are
loved you are loved all over the country
I will tell you that Georgia Republican
party chair somebody that's worked very
closely with me and somebody that has
really fought the good fight on the
fraud that's taken place in your state
and he's fighting it right now he's got
so much information and he wants to
release it and I guess he will be
hopefully he will be soon but he's a
wonderful guy the chairman David Shaffer
David thank you Republican party great
job
a man who is running for governor who is
a friend of mine I said you know you
ought to be a Republican
he said well I don't know but I sort of
like a lot of Republicans and here's the
view of a lot of Republicans and he
really is he's a good man he's a great
guy he's smart he's tough Vernon Jones
Vernon thank you
thank you
wow
thank you
I just heard this guy's here you know he
was a tough cookie he was a great Police
Commissioner of New York
I'm looking for you Vernon this is like
in a very low key way one of the
craziest rallies Trump has actually done
when you really analyze it first for its
substance
thank you
see he's a rebel he's a rebel
that's what people like about him good
thank you Vernon appreciate it a man who
did a tremendous job in New York he was
a a big fan of Rudy Giuliani who's a
great guy by the way my question is
Judgment already in the history of the
city of New York that I can tell you and
did a great job they'd come at him with
barrels they just want to blow people
away it's a disgrace but this is a man
who's tough as hell tough as nails and
did an incredible job in New York he's
respected and loved by anybody and
everybody Bernie Carrick is around here
someplace where's Bernie what isn't he a
criminal as well
um thank you for the 200 Super Chat I
guess this is my first Super Chat
longtime fan year plus member thank you
let's look up Bernie carrick's credit
tonight we have Rich McCormick and Jake
Evans thank you
thank you very much
yeah Bernie Carrick great guy pled
guilty to felony tax fraud
and lying to White House officials okay
I'll be the king I want to thank you
thank you alvita she was with me when it
wasn't so good a thing
he was tough she's tough and she's
wonderful she's a wonderful woman thank
you elevator I appreciate very much you
being here
and this is an acrylicious crowd look at
this crowd of Patriots and the love the
love
the love they have
and you know as we speak
there are people that are being held
prisoner very unfairly
and that should not be allowed to happen
or if it is going to happen you have to
treat
all of the other sides whether it's
antifa or BLM or others that burn down
our city oh is he sang his rioters are
being held unfairly it's one of the
things we learned a long time ago of
course now they're trying to sell
different history books than we used to
get but we're not going to let that
happen
but we have people and Ashley Babbitt
who was killed she was the person that
was killed during that
day that lousy day that horrible day but
they killed Ashley Babbitt and there was
no reason to kill what was horrible
about it no reason whatsoever so our
hearts are with that group and uh
hopefully that's going to all work out I
think in the end it's going to all work
it was a lousy it's a very very unfair
very very unfair situation when you see
them burning down our cities like
Portland a lousy day incited by me and
perpetrated by you Seattle they take
over Seattle people get killed nothing
happens to them and then you see what
happened in Washington DC it's a
disgrace under our Administration we
accomplish it was just a bad day guys
you know sometimes you wake up and it's
just it's not a great day and there's
really no one or nothing to blame it's
just a bad day I thought possible no
president and I say this and I don't get
criticized no president or certainly
very few have accomplished what we
accomplished in four years it's like one
of those examples of just you use
passive language a police officer was
beaten with a flag
okay but hold on who beat that's very
that's like that's the reverse language
usmca that's Mexico and Canada who were
both doing big numbers on our country
but not anymore we withdrew from the job
killing trans-pacific partnership stood
up to China like nobody has ever stood
up taking in billions and billions of
dollars from China when we never took in
10 cents from China that's what we were
just saying was sunny we gave them a lot
of money 28 billion out of that money or
we had a lot left over
but Joe Biden is obliterized he's just
obliterating much obliterizing that was
a bit of a glitch huh we had we had hard
hard one success
and that success is going to have to
come back or our country doesn't stand a
chance we're not respected anymore as a
country we're being laughed at all over
the world Afghanistan was the single
most embarrassing event in my opinion
that's ever happened to our country
the economy added up
to one-third the jobs that we expected
so we expected to have much better
employment numbers and it didn't work
out too good
the unemployment rate for black
Americans increased to a very very high
8.8 percent you know with me they were
way down and going a lot lower gas
prices in Georgia are now almost 100
percent higher than they were just last
year well yeah it's the summer and we
just recovered in in part from covid
massive tax increase that's bigger than
a tax increase inflation is rampant and
shortages are becoming widespread for
all thanks Lisa everybody having trouble
getting products everybody probably
meanwhile Biden and Congressional
Democrats are pushing the largest tax
increase in the history of our country
we can't let that happen the largest tax
is going to kill everything that we
built and what's happening with our
country our foundation was so strong
that they're able to get away with it
for a little while but eventually those
foundations will start to crumble
their socialist legislation would cost a
mind-boggling 3.5 trillion dollars over
ten thousand dollars from every living
American
if you want high taxes fewer jobs vote
for the radical left Democrats if you
want low taxes more and more and more
jobs fantastic income and freedom vote
for Republicans that's what's happening
that's what's happening
Biden in the meaningless pablum every
lever of the federal government to
impose woke nonsense on every facet of
American Life pushing toxic critical
race Theory into our children's
classrooms and even into our military
and male athletes are now being allowed
what do you guys think will he address
getting vaccinated or did it go too bad
last time he did it and so he won't
because the crowd will boom did you see
the he said weightlifting contest how
did that work out
they're fighting for years and years
over two ounces two ounces more I want
to get two ounces more this guy comes
along
and he wasn't even a weightlifter right
so yeah it's so crazy
and it's so unfair to women they fought
so hard to get in this position and it's
so unfair to me yeah if you think this
crowd loves Trump wait till he tries to
suggest vaccination they we learned they
turn on him
deranged resistance campaign the likes
of which our country has never seen
before it was a lie and another lie and
lie after lie and hoax after a hoax a
Witch Hunt after Witch Hunt you saw it
go on with Russia Ukraine with all of
them
and now it's worse than ever before
and the same people are perpetrating
these lies and these witch hunts to say
people they get up they have no shame
they stand up and they talk like it's
such a horrible thing and it's just a
disaster Nancy Pelosi's unselect
committee yeah he's really losing the
crowd
um this guy seems just annoyed with
having to be here still This Woman's
just like working on her wrists she
seems to be having a wrist issue that
she's trying to work out
a lot of people over here are looking at
something off to our left
um blacks for Trump have mostly been on
their phones for the last half hour it's
it's getting they're he's losing them
[Applause]
glitchy video from rsvn
[Music]
the whole world is laughing at us
but is there any place better to be than
a trump rally
a little self-centered there
who was that a picture of up on the
screen
[Applause]
in conclusion everyone here tonight
knows that the extreme left will stop at
nothing to destroy the America we love
in the American dream
but with all of you in Georgia and
conservative Patriots all across the
nation we will end there A Reign of
radicalism in Washington D.C forever
with the Republican Congress we will
fight for more jobs for Georgia families
fair trade for Georgia workers
always have the feel of a fourth grade
book report
in conclusion
[Music]
[Applause]
and you know they are starting to say
very strongly Merry Christmas remember
when I first ran I said you got to say
Merry Christmas they're all saying Merry
Christmas again we better move fast
because that'll end also like everything
yeah it's like it's so weak to say in
conclusion it's like if I was doing one
of these things I would start my
conclusion by by getting the crowd fired
up rather than oh conclusion I would say
so here's the bottom line my friends are
you right or you you you're still
Shifting the section put a disaster
action release
once and for all in our country just as
I had already done very successfully
more so than has ever taken place at our
border we had done it before
we will hold China accountable for
unleashing the virus and for the
unfathomable suffering thank you
judge them trillions of dollars in
reparations
we will reign in big Tech monopolies
reject left-wing cancel culture and we
will restore the right to free speech in
America you don't have free speech
anymore
it's been lost it's over you don't have
a free press anymore we will protect it
the Press we don't have a free press and
yet the media is too free to criticize
Trump make put that one together guys
judeo-christian values and principles of
our nation's
[Music]
there's no free press and Sue the New
York Times because they wrote something
negative
these are great great Patriots and law
enforcement generally our 100 support
they will not be defunded
we will ban critical race theory in our
classrooms we will also ban the virus
from the workplaces and we will ban it
from our federal state and local
governments we will restore patriotic
education for our schools and we will
teach our children to love their country
honor our history and to always respect
our Great American flag
we're pumping it up huh
all right guys let's take bets YMCA when
he's done or not what do you think
[Applause]
our country is up against
some of the most Sinister forces and
entrenched interest that anyone has ever
seen in our country we've never seen
anything like is happening today but no
matter how big or powerful they may
appear you must never forget this nation
does not belong to them this I forgot
about this guy this guy almost seems to
be asleep now it belongs to you those
back in Action this is your home this is
your heritage and our magnificent
American Liberty is your god-given right
the citizens of the United States of
America will not be told how to live how
to think what to do or what to say by
corrupted and competent politicians no
they'll be told by Trump tyrants
left-wing bullies or anybody else
because we are a free proud and
Sovereign people and we have to take
back our country
we are descended from the heroes and
Patriots it actually says a lot that
this this is the only guy really who can
get people on the right even it all
fired up like I know he's sort of lost
the crowd but the fact that this is this
is all they have nothing this is all
they have tears to build this
this and the history of the world and we
are not going to let it be taken away
from us
our ancestors summoned the courage to
fight and win our Independence against
the most powerful Empire on Earth our
parents grandparents and
great-grandparents stormed the beaches
to crush fascism they found the strength
to topple communism and we will not be
afraid of woke lunatics who despise
everything those Heroes fought so hard
for and those Heroes fought and died for
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no Summit we cannot reach there
is no challenge we cannot meet as long
as we remember that we are Americans and
there is nothing that America that's
almost verbatim a Biden line that Biden
uses too
we will not Bend
we will not
we will not
we will never give in we will never give
up we will never back down we will never
ever surrender
[Music]
my fellow Americans our movement has
just begun in fact
I hope that's not true has only I was
hoping it was over
[Applause]
the greatest movement in any country and
we're going to make it's a little bit
pompous
to the end our country will be stronger
than ever before
[Applause]
because the fact is We Are One movement
one people one family and one glorious
nation under God
so with love of our nation
swelling in our hearts and the spirit of
America staring in our souls I say these
words to you tonight God bless we will
make America powerful again the United
States
we will make America wealthy again
oh God we will make America strong again
we will make America proud again you
guys calling for a pizza we will make
safe again
and we will make America great again God
bless you Georgia God bless you thank
you thank you
there it is YMCA they did do it
will he dance I guess is the next
question
actually getting visual distortions from
the base it's interesting
[Music]
fireworks
[Applause]
[Music]
so quite a deranged end all over the
place speech from Trump trump clearly
sort of annoyed it seems that the
Arizona artist did not go in his favor
the crowd uh
engaged at times and at other times
really not at all really not at all and
I think the big news is that there was
much more of a focus now on 2022
is it still too loud it's hard to tell
the bundle mixes right
um
yeah so anyway it does seem as though
the focus is now moving to the midterms
and that's uh not not an altogether huge
surprise
um thanks to 106 of you who either got a
twitch Prime subscription or a
membership at jointpaclin.com we did
start with some pretty serious technical
errors today
um to be honest I don't even really know
how I fixed them
and unfortunately I now don't remember
all the different settings I tried
so if it happens again we'll basically
be starting from scratch
[Music]
wow
people can't hear me
the music's still too loud
how about now is this any better
we doing better now
well
listen the stream's basically over so it
kind of is is fine either way so thanks
to everybody who did join me
um we are going to keep working on
technical elements
yeah and um we're gonna see everybody
very soon okay thank you for joining me
take care
get home safe